that is according to this year's global
500 rankings the world's most powerful
company knocking well Disney off its
perch just last month
today Lego announced its revenues hit a
record high 4.4 billion pounds last year
up 6% on 2015 and with franchises like
the Lego Batman movie which in just four
weeks has made 150 million dollars in
the US and 25 million pounds here in the
UK there's every chance of building on
that success this year
vally patter became the first non Danish
chief executive in Legos 85-year history
when he took over the beginning of the
end he joins us now from the group's
headquarters in the Danish town of
Billund so mr. Pollak an evening to you
you've announced record sales but annual
growth at 6% was the slowest since 2007
it's the brand losing momentum at all
absolutely you know for us if we look at
the sales that we've had up until 2015
I'll you know we call it supernatural I
don't think any company can maintain it
for over a decade so where we are now I
believe is more sustainable and this is
where you know we can also look forward
to getting the product in the hands of a
lot more children around the world in
the United States sales were flat I
think that would come as a surprise to
some people given the success of the
Lego Batman movie the Batman movie has
only just released beginning of February
so looking at where we ended up in 2016
States yes it was flat but if I go back
to 2015 it was a record year and
continue to build on such a big base
it's something that we find a bit
challenging this is what this is the nut
we have to crack as we go forward
you've financed a big investment in your
Factory in Monterrey in Mexico recently
it has not had an impact on American
sales given the anti-mexican rhetoric
from President Trump do you think no we
don't see that and at the moment you
know it's rhetoric it's speculation so
we just have to see what happens where
we land and then we take it from there
about here in the UK obviously you
opened the big Lego store in Leicester
Square recently my wife and kids went
there they had to queue for about 20
minutes to get in there is
is that living up to your expectations
yes it is I mean I've been there quite a
few times and I can understand what
you're saying about the queues we're
trying to do everything we can to reduce
them but it's definitely living up to
expectation this is a great great store
it's a great experience you immerse
yourself in what Lego is all about when
you go in that store
now you raised your wholesale prices at
the beginning of the year by 5% the
amount that you charge retailers to
stock you how what sort of evidence have
you got are they passing that on or they
absorbing the hit themselves and was
that enough to make up for the loss in
Sterling because of the fall in the
pound I mean in terms of passing it on
whatever I mean that's up to the
retailer we made a judgment call as to
what was happening with the pan and what
we had to adjust by and we made the
adjustment from January right but but
and was that enough to make up for you
any loss of revenue due to the fall in
the pant yeah I mean who knows exactly
where we can hurl annulus is just sort
of six seven weeks of sales so far but
that was estimate that you know we have
to do this to remain even now one of the
other big commitments that the companies
made are in prior to you becoming CEO
was that you would be making fully
sustainable plastic by 2030 be using
sustainable plastic by 2030 that's quite
a long lead time is there any
opportunity to bring that in and bring
that deadline forward a bit I mean it is
a long leave time good because we're
trying to invent new materials that do
not exist as if those materials existed
you know we would go for it we had
announced an investment of 1 billion
Danish Krone I in 2015 and today we have
70 very dedicated and talented people
working on this continuously and in the
press conference earlier that shared
some prototypes of what we are finding
so we're on a good path we've set
ourselves a target of 2030 to be both
out of the product and also the
packaging materials that we put our
product into so it's it's a long journey
for us we have to invent new materials
and it will take time unfortunately
I've got to ask you what's it like being
the first non Danish chief of of Lego
does that put a lot of additional
pressure on you no I mean I've been with
the company 14 years and you know in the
time I've been in the company I think I
spend more time in Denmark than I've
done in the UK so yeah to me it's about
running a company understanding what the
ethos of the company is it's about the
children you know we talked about
inspire and develop the builders of
tomorrow how do we continue to do that
and you have whether you're a Dane or
non Dane